viene a tutti ragazzi e tre minuti a
questo video sono dei liguri games sto
parlando io non so se ti dispiace però
che gli skate contest science of change
questo già lo sapevo è la madonna
siamo ragazzi su don il boss with
superpower che sarebbe ragazzi don't
work your bones week superpower quindi
sempre dove si mescolano le persone però
stavolta con i superpoteri quindi non è
che l'anci solo i coltelli in faccia e
poi vieni lanci con la forza di majin bu
fare una partita decente vedo se riesco
a che cosa c'era di così importante in
questi quattro fogli mi stavi
descrivendo come mai se è ancora vergine
a 80 anni cosa che cos'è sta roba il
martello di thor i faccioni provare il
martello di thor così sa bene perché lui
[Musica]
dopo questa scena dovreste prendere un
martello vero e martellare proprio il mi
piace sul monitor no perché non so
quanta epicità c'era in st l'arto non è
mai stato naruto la vita è una menzogna
fuoco ragazzi stasera vale tutto il
video ecco questa è la sarebbe la mano
di spider man perché c'è doraemon vicino
video che adesso prendo la mano di
spider man mano non l'hai prec avevi già
invece esclusa fratte c'avevo il potere
di spiderman veloce star ii contro
qualcuno ma non è che vecchio che che
vecchio che era perché non poter
riuscire tranquillamente non dovevi
attaccarti al soffitto e uscire perché
se non eri abbastanza figo ragazze non
gli artigli wolverine mica troppo e
l'art il 9 gli artigli nascosti nel
cassetto giusto bello ce l'ho anch'io
nascosti proprio affetto la bistecca con
quelli veri ne fanno un cazzo lui
l'aveva bene che a rho che adesso credo
che gli e freni un po che ti trattano
diventato sushi ragazzi per adesso il
martello di thor è il migliore cioè non
ho visto ancora niente di più
tu sei io non conosco i film di
supereroi fini non conosco tutti una
tasca dove tiri fuori tutte le cose
certo in teoria vicino a te c'è un
ragnetto ecco perfetto schiacciando il
ragnetto
la carità è morto ma potresti smetterla
e morto che te sarà la porta lì era più
facile vabbè mi fate trovare una cura
costante dio
fatevi mettere addosso la madre ecco
infatti o cazzo questo era quello di
star trek cosa bellissima
vabbè non questo a queste bellissime c'è
la ford a gesù che non usano le porte ma
che problema c'è con le porte sto
cristiano ragazzi non può uscire dalla
porta normalmente solo col martello di
thor è uscito normalmente quelle altre
cose non a recco i pugnetti della
madonna si ricorda qualsiasi cosa tu
faccia ricordati dice laporta è morto mi
sa che la porta l'aborto perché c'è un
righello hai un flauto a e flauto volo
che chiama chi chiamava sapevo non lo so
però chiama qualcuno di grosso mi pare
a giudicare da come trema la stanza e
qualcuno di grosso poi mia madre dopo
che ha visto il mio 4 da uguale anche
mia madre faceva così però è qualcuno il
più grosso di mia madre è la madonna di
piazza e consiglia è un po violento sa
cosa mi devi prendere tu vero perché non
posso uscire dalla porta giusto allora
perché non avevo dubbi che sarei uscito
dal detto tranquilli siamo arrivati a 7
su 13 trattami che sono 13 reggono 13
coi io non vedo già più niente
il cubo di rubik li metto a fare il cubo
di rubik e davanti
no mi sa che queste transformers ha già
è vero il tubo di trasforma mi sa che
c'hai leggermente nel didietro però non
vorrei stratico potrebbe essere ancora
vivo e non si sa mai talaltro non
abbiamo sporcato cosa di batman giusto
puoi uscire dalla porta informatica ci
aveva provato in retromarcia poi ha
deciso di sfondare il muro però apprezzo
il tentativo niente ragazzi e un arto
non lo posso cliccare per carità sarebbe
stato troppo figo cliccare naruto però
vabbè ma questa non la conosco ragazzi
abbiate pazienza a san siro pazzo
fighissimo è uscito dalla porta serio si
è scemo non ama questo si è fumato
qualcosa le mancano tre ragazzi che non
so liman the hub è superman ma se non ci
fosse stato super me mi sarei spaventato
leggermente guarda come voi sapete che
vota
non credo che tornerà indietro per
uscire dalla porta te ne andrai
direttamente era necessario fare questa
cosa potevi semplicemente andare in cima
al palazzo e zio
madonna cos'è sta roba bellissimo il
palazzo ai proprio demolito e che credo
che sia morto non sono convintissimo
però non c'è neanche più a c'è la scarpa
comprate le nuove geox la scarpa che
resiste ai supereroi che poi morì te
però la scarpa no allo ragazzi ne
mancano tre che non ho visto che manca
ancora la gomma questa la gomma chiama
cancella qualsiasi cosa anomala era la
lamina dovuto persone con nard comunque
questo non è naruto e nardò
se non vorrei che vi sbagliando tutto
perfetto
la tecnica della moltiplicazione del
corpo in una stanza che ci stanno due
cristiani in croce comunque se
continuate così muore domani e ragazzi
non vorrei di m ok perfetto passerai
mica dalla porta no però ci ho provato
undici su tredici ragazzi gli ultimi non
li troverò mai nella vita credo prove ok
con oggetti stiamo scherzando
cos'è sta roba hai la tasca di prima non
l'ho già fatta la grafica su scemo manca
sono anche ragazzi di strano una palla
cos'è che chi esce un cane fa mica
nostra del drago e quella è una sfera
tel tra cosa involti sharon a notte a
ranzi giusto perché lui con la sfera del
drago diventa super sayan te
non si sa come né perché
panoramica non ho mai visto un
animazione così [ __ ] neanche in dragon
ball sul serio fatemi indovinare userà
il teletrasporto
io sono io sono un veggente ma neanche
le caio veramente confido nella
tredicesima ragazzi l'ultima kill sarà
quella decisiva dove uscirà dalla porta
sono convinto si metterà una vita e
mezzo a trovarla prova beh hai voglia di
spiegarmi come faccio a trovarla in
tutto sto bordello non veramente voglio
capire dove minchia emma non troverò mai
nella vita
a meno che non sia io direttamente
titoli non era un libro sta cosa ho
sempre creduto fosse lì non era un libro
ai boss
io sono sono fatto tua figlia ti ho
tagliato un braccio a caso perché se n'è
accorto dopo ti sei accorto di non avere
la mano e vabbè queste sono cose che
succedono per carità
faccio anche la forza per carità di dio
ci mancava quella fra te e hai mangiato
sushi
no perché si vede non ho visto cosa ha
fatto perché sto guardando lo stomaco
del tizio che ora non è uscito dalla
porta questo son sicuro cava ragazzi
almeno una volta l'ha fatto quindi la
prezzo andiamo su perché stai guardando
queste cose spiega miss i legami che
cosa c'è di intrattenimento in questa
cosa ah no se io lo faccio senza
coltello sembra una cosa bruttissima
accordo ragazzi ha concluso anche walk
and your boss superhero star madonna che
titola sta roba
i ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
spero che ne escano altri perché io sti
giochi quali non lo so perché ma mi
piacciono sempre spero che usate dalle
porte perché questo gioco non insegna ad
uscire dalle porte ma voi fatelo perché
non è sicuro a correre contro il muro e
uscire dal muro io lo so ci ho provato
che i ragazzi servizio è piaciuto ma sul
dosso documento è un mi piace agli
afgani feci perché con i video tratta
descrizione senza che si discute di ci
vediamo la prossima vita dei ragazzi